it seems like there was this big  backlash and everyone was just concerned  with this and it it took everyone's  intentions away from your relationship  with the Caitlyn and you Josh you kind  of told her that you had this male  intuition that he wasn't right but I  don't think you really knew knew who he  was and you said the same thing about JJ  night to Caitlyn said that we're not  good in the house well no didn't really  know me and I like I just asked you one  question before you answer yeah don't  you think that by saying that someone  else isn't right for her that you are  valuing your opinions above hers I mean  if you if you are telling her that your  intuition is that this other guy is bad  then you're saying that you know better  than her and this show wasn't Josh finds  a wife for Caitlyn you know or any of us  finds a wife brocaded  right it's about her deciding who's  right for her